this is our definitive collection of the
absolute most pause worthy moments in
the past and Furious franchise not just
the coolest scenes but the actual
moments that had you picking your jaw
off the floor and theater audiences
howling disbelief their fun in their own
way but the first three movies in the
past franchise clearly follow a pretty
predictable formula right up until the
third one enters its final act to put it
kindly Tokyo Drift is the most
polarizing entry in the series ditching
DOM and Brian in favor of country boy
Shawn Boswell and retired racer Han Liu
late in the film as they tear through
the pack city streets racing for their
lives pawns car struck suddenly while
going through an intersection Shawn
bolts from his own car to help Han who's
trapped in bleeding in the wrecked car
but the gas ignites pawns death shocked
fans and elicited true gasps in the
theater his art resonated with audiences
who watched him overcome a tragic pass
to buy a new purpose through Shawn I've
simple to make choices and you don't
look back
fans loved how Hans disaffected lilten
playfulness contrasted beautifully
against the chest-thumping bravado of
the other racers making his death sting
that much more this moment is monumental
in the franchise it solidified Tokyo
Drift as a central viewing and set in
motion the arc that would dominate the
next decade of the saga and when Han
came back for the fourth fifth and sixth
films we needed to pause things just to
figure out the timeline when a grieving
han tells the crew he's moving to Tokyo
in Fast & Furious 6 you could feel the
entire theater sit up and pay attention
everyone wondered if that was it was the
loop closed now then a surprise epilogue
floored everyone playing back Hans death
from a new angle it turned out that this
was no random collision stunned we
watched Deckard Shaw emerge from the
other car and coldly tossed Letty silver
cross necklace into the wreckage with
Hans still trapped walking away dexhart
leaves a threatening voicemail for
dominic toretto as the car explodes
behind him with an impact that's still
being felt in the ninth film Hans death
both times is without a doubt the most
paused moment in the entire series it's
hard to remember a time when the fast
series wasn't the ridiculous basically
super heroic juggernaut it is today but
it's easy to figure out where the
turning point is Fast Five punched
audiences right in the face right from
its high-octane intro on a lonely desert
road the gang launches a daring assault
on a prison
the action slows to a dramatic crawl as
the bus flips over Brian's car and
careens along until we smash cut into
the title card this introduction is
simply brilliant Fast Five managed to
introduce its main players blast the
plot into overdrive and set the new
standard for its wild action all in
under 90 seconds if that wasn't enough
it also showed us that the past
franchise is apparently set in the same
universe as Parks and Recreation or at
least they cast the same actor who plays
perd hapley compared to the extremes the
franchise would go to later the bus
flipped pales in comparison but the raw
thrill of such a tightly paced opening
remains a highlight of the franchise
even when they're facing down seemingly
impossible odds that could lead to
certain doom Dom Toretto and his crew
very rarely show anything resembling
fear that is gotta go to work
in Furious 7 though there's one sequence
where they're definitely justified in
being a little worried we see them in a
dark space and then the floor opens up
to reveal they're in cars in the hold of
a cargo plane that does not seem to be
coming in for a landing any time soon
we've seen some insane stuff in the six
movies before this but would they really
go skydiving inside cars of course they
would
the vast franchise is full of ridiculous
stunts but nothing comes close to this
one why because it's real
they dropped actual cars out of an
actual plane the series has always aimed
for real stunts whenever possible and it
cannot be stressed enough that happened
it's an incredible feat and a moment
that earns a pause and honestly we'd be
scared too this franchises relationship
with the laws of physics has always been
a contentious one but fast and furious
sakes went from exaggerating to
flagrantly disregarding with its
infamously
awesome tank scene if a full on army
tank tearing down the highway wasn't
enough things really get out of control
when Dom sees that Letty is about to be
thrown off a bridge at high speed
naturally he climbs on top of and leaps
from his own car flying across the
bridge to catch her midair before
breaking his impact against the
windshield we might be wrong but we've
only seen that kind of catch in one
other place
easy miss I've got you to put it mildly
we have questions how Kadam have
possibly calculated his trajectory and
maybe more importantly how are they not
dead again best lives inspired casting
of Dwayne Johnson as the relentless
government-backed bounty hunter Luke
Hobbs is one of the biggest reasons the
franchise well and truly took off from
the incident he steps off that plane
Johnson steals every scene he's in with
Hobbes's intensity and unexpected quirky
humor while he's immediately ahead to
the scene that cemented the rocks place
in the franchise was the chase seen
through the favela and Brazil while DOM
and crew desperately fleeing it's
attempted by a local crime lord they
remain unaware of a second more
dangerous threat Hobbs
as he leaps between rooftops Tom looks
back midair to see Hobbs bulldozing
through a window after him it's worth
pausing the action here for a lot of
reasons but watching Vin Diesel and
Dwayne Johnson exchanged their first of
many in character looks of pure hatred
is definitely one of them especially
considering the real-world route the two
actors took the franchise in from there
like the tank catch Tom's big escape
plan from Furious 7 is a must pause
moment just not for the right reasons
after Tom rescues hacker Ramsey the bad
guy keeping her captive traps him
against the cliff with mercenaries on
one side and a sheer drop on the other
Tom smiles before launching into a
pretty sick burnout kicking up a cloud
of dirt that obscures everything a
reasonable person even in the fnf
universe might expect that Don would
escape in the confusion but that's not
nearly absurd enough for this movie he's
still there and all that dust was just
to spin his car around to face that clip
with that and with Ramsey making the
smart decision to put on a helmet Tom
floors it and goes over the cliff and
this time there's no parachute to slow
him down he seems to crash into every
rock along the way until finally the car
lands upside down and Tom emerges
brushing himself off and of course is
absolutely fine it's one way down a
moment you'll need to pause this moment
just to figure out what the hell
happened and how they're not dead that
must have been one heck of a good helmet
with all their talk about the importance
of family and the literal world saving
exploits of the later films it's easy to
forget that dominus crew or career
criminals the big heist at the end of
past five serves as a good reminder and
one of the
wildest sequences in the franchise Brian
and Dom have just ripped a 9,000 pound
steel vault onto the packed city streets
of Rio de Janeiro they've got it chained
to the respective car swinging it around
like a wrecking ball as they tear around
corners and smashing into the local cops
for collisions that are definitely not
going to leave a lot of survivors don't
worry though we're told that literally
every police officer in the city is
corrupt so that part's fine when they
take a sharp turn that sends the vault
careening into a crowded bank full of
terrified citizens however their actions
in pursuit of money are a little less
lovable the entire sequence is
incredible from start to finish but that
moment with the bank stands above the
rest if you pause it to see the people
scrambling out of the way you also get a
chance to think about how Hobbs might
have been onto something when he tried
to arrest these guys whether you like
these movies are not there remains an
undeniable objective truth they're
imaginative in a way most modern action
movies aren't the stunts here are so
unbelievable so off-the-wall that it
feels like only a child could have
designed them case in point the zombie
carpocalypse of the fate to the Furious
as part of a plot for world domination
that seriously involves blackmailing a
street racer ultra hackers cipher takes
control of an army of self-driving cars
to cause chaos in New York City and then
it gets really wild not content just to
use the cars already on the ground
cipher decides to make it rain with
dozens of cars pouring down from a
parking garage like two-ton hail the
only problem with watching these movies
in the theater is that a moment like
this demands to be paused rewatched and
paused again as you shriek and utter
disbelief at how cool that was we all
know how chicken is played two people
drive straight at each other each
determined not to pull away first under
normal circumstances someone swerves at
the last minute but this is fast and
furious and these drivers are Dom
Toretto and Deckard Shaw both men are so
using with pride and machismo that
Furious 7 features not one but two
scenes where our badass leads decide to
take it to the extreme and go for the
brutal head-on collision both times the
first is a true jaw dropper on its own
that closes out a climactic chase scene
we know these guys are tough and that
they always wear their seatbelts kids
but this is a whole new level
they plow into each other with a kind of
force that would lead to a busy night at
the morgue here in the real world these
guys though Deckard pops his neck and
emerges without a scratch Dom climbs out
a little worse for wear but still fine
both cars are totaled masses of twisted
steel and these dudes are still ready
for fistfights for a giant hammer fights
in Dom's case somehow the second time
this happens manages to be just as if
not more shocking than the first doing
it once is one thing that's already
crazy but twice head-on doing 80 and Dom
can still swing around to comically
large wrenches we should have sent these
guys to fight Thanos The Fast and the
Furious was about an undercover cop
infiltrating illegal street racers who
sometimes boost VCRs and VCR TV combos
kids ask your parents what those are
more than 15 years and a blockbuster
franchise later the fate of the Furious
sees the same racers now recruited by a
secret agent who's saving the world from
a cyber terrorist threatening literal
nuclear annihilation
it's been a journey no moment
illustrates that better than submarine
racing across a Tundra to escape boards
of Russian soldiers the gang already has
the odds stacked against them then a
literal nuclear submarine explodes
upward from the frozen lake below
sending a few trucks or what's left of
them flying in all directions as it too
begins chasing the crew for a second
press pause and imagine you haven't seen
any of the movies since the first one
and now you're watching this moment do
you think this lady was really mad about
her VCRs check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]